good morning Millennials so sorry
that we started a little late today I
got a call from Hillary Clinton and I
just had to take and I couldn't hang up
on her a little rude of her obviously
not to know that my show starts at 10:30
but who am I to you know hang up on what
could have been the first lady first
president she was so intent on speaking
to you that she took the Wi-Fi down in
our building yes so just don't worry
about that
we're actually extra special
announcement we are officially only
streaming on YouTube ever again Facebook
of Mark Zuckerberg he just can't handle
the bandwidth and that is the morning
toast like the colors the lights the
sound it's obviously too much for him
and I understand that that's difficult
for him and I no longer want to
embarrass him so we are this is an hour
YouTube show congratulation so excited
that's all I've ever wanted for my life
so it's just a strictly YouTube show
instead of being like we should mind
Facebook YouTube Instagram like slowly
but surely we were whittling it down to
be an excessive stream on Instagram when
we were janky as hell it was called the
morning jank yeah
both good morning everyone I'm not
watching we've now both decided to put
our phones away because even on a day
when everything works like we both are
really just you look at her too much and
it's helpful for people for me to be
able to see the comments but Margo if
there's anything important going on you
will let us know if we're not live and
we're talking to know about it just
please let us know yeah audio let us
know you know well good morning everyone
today is Wednesday November 7
Oh November 7th the day after Jackie's
birthday the day I'm headed to Charlotte
tonight I've never been to Charlotte I
have been to Raleigh I'm very excited to
head down to the land of the pines I'm
doing two shows the first one sold out
the second show does have a couple
tickets available as of last night I
don't really know cuz like they're in
such hot demand but the second show was
gonna be even more like because the
points guys coming and he brought he's
such a good friend like he bought he
brought like his headquarters is there
so he brought like ten employees and it
was gonna be like a good friend give him
the tickets play consisted I'm putting
it on his business and I was like okay
twist my arm write it off anyways as we
were saying this is my first show is a
26 year old and you're really aging out
is what I heard the bosses say right
that I'm they're gonna have to use me
for audio only some no but I feel like
in the hosting realm ages is a plus when
it's age comes wisdom are you saying
in the hosting realm age isn't just a
number no it is still a number and will
always be a number but it might be a
more positive we're actually feel like
they may be that in hosting like the
more respect you yeah like the more
opportunities you get no one wants a
young host which is weird cuz you think
that they do want a young host and then
I'm sure the old hosts are being told
you're too old and the young hosts are
being told you're too young so what is
the age alignment or just they always
complain about not having millennial
audiences but like refuse to cut it for
big put a millennial on TV so they just
like teach six-year-olds how to say
millennial things they're like yo that's
what you know I'm shook yeah but I'm
here for it that sounds like an episode
of busy tonight
overall I'm shook it's did you watch
yesterday I'm here for no because I was
enjoying my birthday I didn't watch
either even though I got into bed and
now that I've changed my HDMI the cable
to watch one night of television it
looks like I'm stuck on cable for a
couple months so I've been watching so
much cable for bed especially shark tank
I can't press the importance of channel
15 and for me it's 15 I know you cut
your cords because you're such a
millennial that you don't know it's
MSNBC where they play all Shark Tank
episode reruns but have you caught up on
the new season yet no so I just finished
the most recent season where they had
Richard Branson Bethany and a rod a rod
and the Vitamin Water guy Raj Raj but
Raj is like more of a regular he is the
smartest and the greatest and he really
brings to the table something the other
sharks don't how much is that he's not
an inventor he's not an entrepreneur he
is a branding expert you know whom he
needs to patch up with he's Elan musk
because Elon Musk wanted to be both the
you know entrepreneur and to provide and
the tech innovative in torinese and
creative while Josh business Elon is
creative I totally agree no I love Raj
and I like want to invest at one time
got an opportunity to invest in
something like years ago and I didn't
have any money what was it something
that he is like owning now is it a big
thing now is it a food or a drink it's a
drink ooh interesante I know also any
really Beyonce's an investor and I'm
like no she's not and she actually
wasn't so I had I had a hundred thousand
dollars back then or now in the first
episode of season 10 which is dealing
episode I've watched so far the guest
shark is someone who was in the tank is
a
no no no no yeah the sponge with the no
oh [ __ ] okay so the shark the guest
shark I'm sure you guys have seen this
it's someone who came into the tank
which in ideaa years yes first of all
who knows - ABC for constantly coming up
with good ideas in regards to shark tank
okay the only it's a bit of a plot twist
though because it's who who did they get
a deal with no one [ __ ] I don't know
ring oh oh my god the billion dollar
company a billion dollars oh my god and
they just did an update on them in the
most previous season that I just binge
on Amazon Prime oh my god that is so I
guess he must be the most successful
shark for them to make him a he must be
the most successful what are you called
shark bait for him to become shark and
this I'm gonna be still some of your
decorations up to keep that memories of
birthdays past yeah for one day the the
second most successful entrepreneur to
step into the tank is also someone who
did not get a deal on the show plated
mm-hm
but later on like a year later they ran
into mr. wonderful out like some
entrepreneurial convention and he ended
up striking a deal with them but on the
show they had gotten to jail with Robert
and it didn't go through because they
say half of shark tank deals in the tank
don't actually end up going through and
Robert like let it go and then mr.
wonderful turned it into a billion
dollar business they reached a billion
dollars in revenue the year after mr.
wonderful came in
good for them anyways shark tank I agree
I wondered what shark tank okay I could
talk about shark tank all day really
can't because we have the queen of New
Jersey joining us in a little bit and I
have to catch a flight so like we have
business to take care of we have a hard
out at 11:30 and you have a hard out at
noon because shot morning toast is only
available for an hour and 20 minutes
longer because it is a 24 hour run so
get everything you need join the
sorority rush toast its bid day season
you guys I got a bunch of questions that
I would just like to quickly address
these items will never be available
again like besides ya know their limited
edition the sorority stuff yeah
everything new that we drop today is
never gonna be available so like if you
don't get it now you're gonna be a
weeding to another question shipping you
should have all of your items within two
weeks we are very efficient everything
ships out in two weeks yeah whatever
three do it thanks for shop morning to
Ascot five sizes go up small to XL a lot
of it double double XL sorry a lot of
the items
unisex so look for that because that
effect sizing it's not the same items as
last time which were more catered to the
female body you know they were too
fitted for me so we can go with
something a little bad gear the t-shirts
actually the Supreme iam t-shirt it's
the most comfortable stretchy shirt like
we were hell bent on getting like
stretchy shirts and we got the greatest
yeah no it's it's a little sexy but now
that when your birthday's over we've
officially like launched into holiday
season well yeah because there's a great
great debate going on in the country
like there's many debates going on in
the country this is one of them
yesterday but one of them is when does
the holiday season start is it October
31st is it thanks post Thanksgiving for
me it's post birthday because between
Halloween and birthday I'm gearing up
for a bird night but then between
Holloway and Christmas I'm gearing up
for Christmas Halloween how between
birthday and Christmas I'm gearing up
for Christmas so now like today is the
first day of the holiday season for me
okay so now that I have like a family in
an apartment like I really wanted you
like a photo shoot like a holiday photo
shoot and like - a Christmas card or
like I'm not even Catholic so like a
holiday card and it would be like
generic like a pink like it wouldn't be
like what's the word when it's like not
a religion nondenominational that's the
one yeah like a picture of me Ben and
Theo like in like little cute sweaters
you think you guys are very much a
religion no yeah but I would send them
to everyone and also like no offense
Hanukkah
but like Hanukkah is lords its no
Christmas no no and if you are doing
holiday cards as a Jewish person you're
supposed to do is during Rosh Hashanah
in which I would have already missed the
opportunity but I don't even know like
where to start
holiday cards I agree and I agree that
you should do a holiday card because you
are a family now and you had a son and
not you not only to have a sudden you
have a son who's a doctor and that's all
a mother can wish for I want to brag you
know to all the other ladies in my bills
right my son became a doctor and a lot
of holiday cards say do you like updates
of what happened this year like we got
married our son graduated from medical
school he's dr. Theo a chairman you can
find him on Google he writes
prescriptions for fun and love and
happiness I'm on tour but good tickets a
girl's no job job
totally anyways if you want to get Holly
get her hearts go to vistaprint that's
where I got my business cards except I
had to get new ones called a las Tres
offer even though like I've literally
never had the opportunity to give anyone
my business card
but I'm looking forward to it but in a
professional manner are
you Claudia joy or Claudia showstopper
both like it just depends I'm seated on
an email now where they keep referring
to me as mrs. I'll sure I saw her and I
just feel like a [ __ ] teacher they
put a - no but most of the time I don't
know I think my shows they actually
billed me as Claudia I saw her Wow
well anyways when you're doing your next
business card order order your holiday
cards from mr. printer because they make
it so easy you can choose any format and
then it really takes the hassle out of
holiday card and you know Vistaprint is
very good about promo codes every time
I'm on the website they're like wait
before you check out use this coat it'll
give you 50% off I can do you one better
I've one more for you get marry get
jolly get 50% off all holiday cards and
calendars plus save on other photo gifts
at Vistaprint comm just enter promo code
toast holiday at Vistaprint calm promo
code toast like us holiday one-word
offer valid until January 31st 2019 you
should have it done by then because if
you're selling great if you're sending
your holiday cards in January it's too
late but a New Year's card I guess
that's why is that a thing
yes but that's holiday okay well I'm
gonna do it
well they say I'm gonna do it we'll see
if I hurry to through the photo shoot
Cobb Anthony - if that's with my first
thought this morning honestly I expect
to receive a holiday card now there's no
excuse obviously if you make the cut oh
okay well without further ado we've
wasted enough time here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast by the I'm getting
so excited for Nashville and like I just
need legal to finish up the paperwork so
you can tell everyone we can chatter
from the rooftop I keep emailing like
where we yeah like everyone to kill me
I'm so excited for Nashville I need it I
need to shout it from the rooftops and I
was thinking about snitches morning
we're trying to get her credential CMAs
if you're watching I mean one more
cadential I know they're really like
wanting to kill me because I applied for
three and I was like you know cuz it's
the two of us and then I'm like maybe
like a cameraman or whatever but the
camera crew that we got like it needs a
million credentials so I keep emailing
for more for like things that we need
like we can't we need audio and now I'm
like I forgot to get Margot one so I'm
like I'm gonna snitch
we need an intern first of all and then
we also need our sister on the red
carpet just to like you know find a man
you know entry singer we're gonna say
this is gonna be like less here we did
take a shot with us this one's gonna be
g18 our sister like we'll have you in a
big a Barbie doll like little plastic
like two and you'll be spinning
yeah she's 21 loves to party is a
graduate of New York University soon
coming May 2017 maybe she'll be summa
[ __ ] laude I don't know and she's never
worried she's always monkey I'd no idea
what you're about sighs I lost it for a
second but came right back you got it
back all right first story something
that we all just uh stumbled our way
through much like ariana grande stumbled
through her emotional performance of
thank you next on The Ellen Show ariana
grande grande isn't perfect perfect nor
does she pretend to be in Wednesday's
episode of The Ellen DeGeneres Show the
25 year old popstar performed her new
single thank you next for the first time
on TV
the first wives inspired number featured
grande and her backup singers Victoria
Monet and Taylor Park wearing all white
at a wedding
the trio's choreography mimics the
finale from the 1996 comedy starring
Goldie Hawn Diane Keaton and Bette
Midler as three friends who sought
revenge on their lousy husband okay
that's why we're making fun of the
choreography and we were like she's
dancing like a mom literally she's
dancing like First Wives Club because I
don't like when Ariana dances I think
her voice is too good like she doesn't
need it but people who like put a
hardcore choreography like JLo she
doesn't even sing anymore she just
dances right it's supposed to be a
distraction and Ariana doesn't need that
and she's pretty much stopped dancing
like she's a dancer like focus on me but
now she doesn't need it and I don't want
her to do it anymore but the greats can
do both I take the budget for that
wedding was like literally like my dream
budget for my wedding you know totally
like with five guests in attendance
three during the second verse grande
stood on one of the chairs to sing
spending more time with my friends I
ain't worried about nothing
plus I met someone else we have better
discussions after stepping down the
high-heeled diva stumbled and shouted oh
my god she fell without missing a beat
no she missed a few B yeah the pop star
managed to recover and laugh at herself
she didn't resume the performance
singing this one gonna last cuz her name
is Ari and I'm so good with that and
then she cried also at the part where
she talked about her she only wants to
get married once which I just like love
cuz everyone's like and how people in
Hollywood don't take marriage seriously
she was like I really only want to get
married once and my dad will walk me
down the aisle
nowhere mom will walk me down the aisle
is she strong cuz she grew from the
drama with her dad I guess I guess her
parents oh yeah and that's when she
started tearing I thought she was
tearing maybe about her grandpa
Margo Google Ariana Grande dad
no she said one day this is it one day
I'll walk down the aisle holding hands
with my mama I'll be thanking my dad cuz
she grew from the drama oh yeah for sure
for sure you want to I wonder what the
drama P upset me to say she went there I
don't think and I said I think jus their
dad I think who dad to her yeah her mom
grew from the drama her mama grew from
the joy yeah I think so too
sorry ariana grande stole rhyming mama
with drama from Taylor Swift and here's
to my mom who ever listened to oh this
job I took me a while to get there sorry
and here's to my baby he and beat him
but they call me lately
and then she also started to laugh again
so she cried during that but she's here
she quit Chile she was a big [ __ ]
mess she quit her during that verse and
then the next line is only want to do it
once real bad gonna make that [ __ ] last
god forbid something happens least as
song as a smash and then she laughed on
that line so I need a home girl
seriously to take a break like this is
just proof like it was funny and cute
and like actually like when she cried I
was like oh that's so sweet but she
really needs to take a break she like
went through a traumatic loss of Malcolm
who really I believe what's her one true
love um and did a very public
relationship and like she's just going
through a lot and like she needs to stop
like the releasing of this one was Cupid
like going to perform it was unnecessary
like Scooter Braun like definitely made
her do that and I just think she really
needs to take a hardcore break and take
it [ __ ] not well when we were reading
her tweets and that's when she was still
with PETA and she was saying can I just
have like one day to myself can I sleep
right and we were just like give it
someone give this girl a break and that
was before she came out with a new song
so like she's back on it I don't what I
gleaned from that performance is not
that she wasn't ready or that she needs
time but it's like I don't even know
what I got at know she definitely
she's like emotional because there are a
lot of emotional things happening I'm
like it's not good to be like non-stop
working traveling everything when you're
going through that like just take a
[ __ ] break yeah she should take a
break she doesn't need the money it's
holiday time that literally nobody works
it's holiday time get your holiday cards
I'm missing and take a break
literally like nobody works starting now
like except for us so just [ __ ] take
a break and come back in January and
then you can respond to all your emails
go to sleep I was only gonna say check
it out
Joe got up I agree so yeah it was like a
kind of sad thing to watch it was but
the song is a smash
of course anyway her dad is not in the
picture and that's why she's thinking it
so thank you I just didn't know that
there was familial su so essentially
what you're saying is in the picture and
that you were that picture and that you
were what what's the word we're looking
for here that's where W is I was monkey
okay
I think she can admit when she's monkey
because someone from your tour made
snitch a needle point of don't worry B
monkey oh yes I know so much and it sits
next to her bed and yesterday she I
meant I wasn't gonna bosses but here we
are she took a nap during my birthday
she slept there with her you did well
because I'd so much to wait to feed Theo
change pack and shower for our trip
today and I couldn't like wait for you
to wake up I'd be waiting until now
why'd you to wait for me he said you
that well no she's yelling at me for
sleeping through her birthday he left
her birthday yeah
oh I left a portent get ready for her
dinner why you want me to show up at the
restaurant like I'm sure so you think
peacefully under my gravity blanket next
to a needlepoint that says don't worry B
monkey and it was the most monkey you've
ever been it was the least worried
actually you've ever read you looks very
cute I meant to take a picture of me but
instead I turned out the light so you
could sleep better oh that was so
generous I saw that you know but you did
he didn't budge no like I felt it happen
but I was asleep yeah talking yeah
when I don't need the comments we might
as well not be live no we couldn't not
be I would live and even know okay
speaking of
spiteful X's Ray J deny spreading sexual
rumors about Kim Kardashian okay this
story is really wild after Kim
Kardashian called ex-boyfriend Ray J a
pathological liar the musician is
denying spreading any rumors regarding
his past sex life is with Kim so he
started a rumor a few days ago that Kim
and they're a good one cuz I'm hearing
that Kim I actually heard it on him
Breakfast Club one of the many recap
shows I'm now watching on position they
took one minute per story they say how
does a breakfast club know most of the
rumors that I'm in play it in the
morning and I just get my daily dose and
I have to say there's a there's so much
trash out there it's such a great show I
love Charlotte means so much I agree
except there was a weird thread about
him and the toasters about like
something not good that he said or did
and yeah well when you're live every day
that shows like 12 hours um
around to say separates deeply
problematic and I also saw an old
interview of him with post Malone when
post Malone was just coming up and he
brought his girlfriend to the show and
by the way postman's now single fan it's
just something to think about
um and Charlemagne was like to him like
you guys are gonna break up like he is
like he's popping off and sure and host
was like no like I'm a good boy and he's
like yeah you're a good boy when no one
knows who you are it seems to be good no
one cares and they're like it was just
so like uncomfortable to listen to in
hindsight I'm a Charla mean as a hustler
like homeboy never stops working never
stops working so good at his job like
him and Morgan Stewart should have their
own show two of the great that is so
good no we need more than one good show
so you say yes dad like they're both
they're meant to be the star and there
can really only be one star there really
can only be one star okay so anyways
rayj like started a rumor that when he
was with Kim Kardashian she had a whole
Louie Vuitton trunk full of sex toys she
spent a hundred thousand dollars a year
on songs and then Kim caught back saying
yet he's a pathological liar oh I'm
sorry I did hear that rumor about the
chest of sex toys yeah quote let me make
this one thing clear Rach I said I'm in
a great place in my life I'm happy I
love my wife I have a beautiful new baby
her name is melody love Norwood and I've
been trying to be the best parent I can
be I would never say these things after
watching my wife go through about grow
through labor for about 28 hours this is
discussing the person I am now is not
who I was in the past I need not to give
me a chance to grow into love and to
respect the people I'm with without
trying to slander my name um so if he
didn't say it then who where did this
come from why am I talking that Ray J
and came again right and also it's like
of course you love your life your wife
is a Kim Kardashian impersonator as is
your daughter just saying um she's
actually no she's not a Kim Kardashian
impersonator the daughter is the North
West impersonator it's literally right
never that's all so I'm [ __ ] Reggie
Bush's oh sorry maybe I'll actually
confuse Reggie Bush's wife and kids are
literally the far - Ian yes they are
full-time in person before - yes yeah so
this is he said he didn't start the
rumor or say he never said it but like
he did say where no one would
like me actually people do them are like
bad rumors like spending $100,000 a year
on thongs it's like funny like if you
have it great
i'ma know when they were dating she
didn't have it like she was cleaning
closets no but she still she can have a
hundred grand but like she and grow up
poor no Brian Calabasas even someone
who's rich even someone who's rich
doesn't spend $100,000 on thongs ci that
might not be true look if I was really
ready to out spend a hundred round on
granny panties like a solid gold it'll
go to Duane Reade of course that's the
best friend
he's so Trudy I hire Hanes to like make
me custom granny panties set up like
built-in Spanx and also like built-in
Tampa
you know yes imagine in the future
there's like robotic underwear that
changes your tampon for you that sounds
amazing
no that does not do it for me um anyway
so it's a he-said she-said story I'm
going I'm team Kim oh hey she said but
also like I believe that Ray J said this
like it's the only time his name was
ever comes up as when he talks about Kim
so yeah he's gonna throw some [ __ ] out
there yeah how do you think he pays his
bills these days like selling stories to
TMZ selling stories to TMZ I don't know
if he comes out with new music but he
definitely like still earns money like
he definitely has like consistent income
from his number one song sexy can adjust
part of it girl wanna shake it Mike a
player like oh it's a Kodak moment let
me go and get my camera
oh you want a Kodak camera use code
toast don't you wish I could use a codec
I could definitely use a codec
sponsorship because like oh my god
remember there was a Kodak store no yes
it's where were you to get our pictures
develop no it was like it wasn't a coup
that's it was because it was called
Kodak really yeah
Yussef stores all the time that was like
a lid every era yeah time periods like
and something that we need to do is I
need to like go through all my photos
something past 10 years and print them
out and put them into photo albums or
else like I'm never gonna see them again
I know especially cuz like every time I
might I'm hop like I see it ugly picture
of myself like I delete it like off of
Facebook and off of the internet so like
I'm really in any year I go through my
whole time up like I'm gonna have no
photos left but I like that I want to
start my life now with my new deck true
I'm not interested in any memories that
include a double chin but you've had
such great memory music we went to the
Super Bowl with your old kid oh that's
true girl Chantay you know I was so good
to my old chin like I took him to the
Super Bowl definitely man I took him to
Europe the like Israel he was cause very
cosmopolitan
my cousin politician by the way also
like if you ever like becomes like we
get the fifth hour on The Today Show
we will have like an animated chin
running around seven teeth chattering
around my chin and he's like has like
stubble and a beer belly and I got he's
always picking his belly button
that's my chin and we'd ever never want
to see him again
likewise your heavens I've has gay shark
yeah or the space boot that like becomes
a galaxy like the shady boot no mana
shey-bui moment by the way did you see a
bit of it yes they did like a plead the
fifth special where they did like the
top ten moments and then like some
honorable mentions and been like I
always have to force him to watch out
stuff but he likes it he was dying it
was so funny it was so funny it's funny
they say like when the celebrities they
could have anyone in there when they do
plead the fifth and like the likes go
down it's like all of a sudden they
think they've they're at like on trial
ya know because like to get a celebrity
that vulnerable is very hard because
they've like the publicist the manager
like everyone like there's so many
levels before you actually get to
celebrity and then it's just Andean and
celebrity and the number one moment you
watch was Jack oh my god and I remember
that we have a size 23 foot how big is
your dick kiss you kiss oh god oh god
my feet are too sweaty for it okay well
he took his shoe and seen the children
up nope okay he took his shoe and went
like this the shoe it was so funny and
that was when they did a show it's out
by right they were in Austin yes that
was when they were like us like just
taking the show on the road any Genki
festival they can hit up yeah that's us
now we've taken the place yeah oh I need
to get a mirror shout out to a toaster
named Katie who went to AC - mmm which
is Andy Cohen and Anderson Cooper's like
tour which I need to go to cuz this need
to figure out what they do and take some
notes they have a Q&A portion and this
girl stood up and was like do you watch
the morning shows and like obviously she
was great but also the toasters
subsequently cheering afterwards like
gave us legitimacy yeah it's not like
this girl was like talking about her
favorite podcast that nobody's ever
heard about like she was like I know
there's some toasters in here like 30
people were like and just thank you to
all you guys and he claimed
never saw an episode or heard about um
yeah but he might have dementia like you
by the way like celebrities like like I
don't know how they remember stuff and
now that I've met like a decent amount
they all I realize how they do it they
all say to me it still needs to see you
and I might keep Bosworth we've never
met and I was like nice to meet you um
speaking of any cons friends Kelly Ripa
is heading to Riverdale as Mark
Consuelos his mistress quote it's a
family affair a dream come true says Us
Magazine but not me Kelly Ripa took to
social media on Tuesday November 6 the
birthday of esteemed morning show host
Jackie a charade to reveal that she'll
be joining her husband Mark Consuelos
and son Michael Consuelos on the hit
show Riverdale quote it's a family
affair
Hiram's mistress 23 years of auditioning
for a role I was born to play coming
soon to the CW ever doubt that was on
the show he's good he's about to play a
young Hyrum Lodge I have to tell you I
saw this and I thought it was just like
a funny caption I didn't think it was
real is it real Margo it's real and I
thought it's a funny caption - I was
like honest about it cuz you wonder why
I saw the caption I was like that's kind
of funny good for her because I think
she's annoying and then she was also on
one of the moments for Andy's top ten of
plead the fifth and that she was being
so funny I'm like maybe she isn't
annoying like maybe she is funny and
then this is actually true so it's like
not that creative
um agreed and I do whenever I see her
I'm honest I were even if I catch her
show I'm always impressed by her and her
and her energy so early in the morning
she's the Energizer but she's a
definition of a morning show host like
that's what you need to wake you up I'm
not here for this story yeah like it's
too much it's too much I didn't like the
young hiram thing is cute but it's like
you can't be a host on mattress because
like when then I either don't believe
you as an actress oh I don't believe as
a hoax you know what's so funny like
this is a really good way to like keep
your eye on your man like he already
gets to kiss Hermione Lodge like once a
season cuz they like never cares but
like a mistress like he would have to
roll around with and Kelly Ripa just
definitely want that to happen so she's
like I can do it yeah I volunteer as
tribute that was Kelly Ripa Marc comes
home from a long day at Riverdale
you know honey they want to give me a
mistress it's not great we're gonna
develop my role so much they are I
volunteer as tribute
that's what happened that's not so so
crazy about actors like the acting life
is like you are making out with people
that aren't your significant other all
the time and it's like how that even
inherently that's an issue
I completely agree any relationship
withstand that I could never be a spouse
of an actor I think that would be super
difficult
I think if both of the actors or spouses
both of the spouses are actors that
makes it a little bit easier to see a
level playing field if it's only one
that's like super hard but like I can't
like if I was an actor I had to make I
was like other hot actors like I
wouldn't be upset about it no but then
like Ben you know he would die he would
come to set and like literally with his
fists Arthur like oh so you're giving us
little brassiere action oh my goodness
this is a children this is a family show
yeah but they also watch mrs. Doubtfire
last night I was playing on free form
which just like take your free form for
constantly giving us like what we need
and a lot of what we don't need okay the
Fosters but my family the shows not a
show about davidenko
not interested David Foster no it's not
that's not the shuttle I know okay right
okay thank you okay you made my point so
he said like the same joke yeah yeah and
I already moved on and I always forget
about the part at the end where like he
gets a TV show like with his voices in
the dinosaurs and I'm like that is the
toast like speaking to the youth totally
that's why the movie speaks Testaments
mr. Rogers and honestly Sally Field was
a big fat [ __ ] [ __ ] in that obey
always be rain she took his kids away
from him no and and like he wasn't a bad
dad not it he's not a great party right
and like when the donkey ate the cake I
was like so upset when I was a kid I was
like did you know what I do for that
cake right now but it's like that's not
something like having a wild party for a
kid and like just bringing a petting zoo
into the home like is not a grounds for
Dibble I completely agree like being a
involved father is certainly not grounds
for a divorce no and like personally I'm
ashamed because Sally Field and I share
a birthday so happy belated birthday
Sally Field so you know when we were
younger like birthday twins birthday
buddy gigas do but like I haven't
checked in my birthday buddies like
since so many new celebrities have like
been born in correct picture Marga would
you tell me my birthday celebrities I
know Jessica Simpson Erika Jayne
that's a really good one um you and
Olivia are so close are you Michelle
Kwan or Azalea is Michelle Kwan I saw
Michelle Kwan at Neiman Marcus once like
when we were kids I'm Alyssa Livia like
[ __ ] yeah
Margaux who shares a birthday with me so
far no one knew got a famous birthday
Stein come here which I happened to be
on me too south Finch I had them update
my picture out you know that I don't
like Thanks so funny they're gonna last
picture of me when I had a fat chin
nobody help that guy came in scotch on
his belly nobody ever Gera had seen
birth is near Garrett their gear oh you
made it like the most American Harry
Edwards whoa this mark over me you owe I
mean Jackie or me yeah okay what a
Chucky Oh Harper Beckham she's seven is
she higher like on the relative like
they have a rank of like this is like
the number like releve on white Harbor
back relevancy and what is mine mine's
like a hundred thousand okay I'll be
really upset if she's like in hundreds
oh she's definitely not in the hundreds
I believe I'm in the hundred thousands
and I think she would be in the
thousands she is she's what 3229 and the
Tatia Tatia is you know where you stand
in the loge odd 17,000 494 that's not
bad I thought at one point I was in the
hundred thousands I just want to say and
this is for all birthdays on July 7th
are all birthday no just birthdays all
celebrity Oh Lamar go do you Jackie's
okay yeah and who are my fellow birthday
buddies I'm gonna kill it moving up on
the seventy nine thirty five thousand
six hundred eighty three okay but why I
feel like her scandal really should have
brought us like a little higher up I
think that was the bump maybe and now
here we are oh so we're so funny we're
like we have to do the show in under an
hour so much you get through I know
who's my birthday buddy is continued
continued next story Alec Baldwin show
bumped to Saturday time sought after
parking spot brawl first of all Alec
Baldwin had a talk show has a talk show
I know I see all that it was on TV and I
just scrolled past it when I should have
watched I saw that mames was watching
the episode with Mike Myers and it
looked very serious but ABC has
delivered a blow to hothead actor Alec
Baldwin by moving his poorly rated TV
show Wow shade to a less desirable
timeslot just days after he was accused
of punching a man over a parking spot
the network a noun
Tuesday that repeats of shark tank will
replace the Alec Baldwin Chow pre-taped
episodes at 10:00 p.m. Sundays effective
November 18th according to Variety the
bloviator Zepa eponymous show will
resume in its new timeslot on Saturdays
at 10:00 p.m. beginning December 8th
well this is so interesting because as
you may or may not know we didn't talk
about it yet but Alec Baldwin hearts
punched someone over a parking spot
earlier this week and Alec Baldwin
really is a hothead okay so that's what
I'm trying to find because John Doe did
a list of like all the terrible things
Alec Baldwin has done in the past ten
years I'm like him nobody really like
talks about it and I was like shocked
cuz I like low-key love Alec Baldwin I
love Donaghy I loved I just love so much
about him okay and okay here here but
then I realize like he's done a lot of
terrible term I'm calling his daughter a
pig 1992 called his driver I'm sorry I'm
just saying it cuz it's honorable I
don't believe in the use of this word a
[ __ ] 1995 arrested for battery 2007
called eleven-year-old rude thoughtless
little pig 2012 violent confrontation
with photographer even though I don't
include that in like elicited bad things
like I would I would do it to 2013 calls
photographer [ __ ] f AG 2014
arrested for disorderly conduct 2018
arrested for assault like he has homeboy
has problems has problems and it's like
why does he keep getting a free pass and
when I first heard this story I was like
oh well you know it doesn't matter what
he does cuz like he's not on a show
anymore but then I was I know he
literally just got his own show yeah
like and you're not gonna behave now you
like it's not even like you're a
character on a show and we need you it's
like you have you're at the helm of your
own talk show behave and like I feel
like if this were anyone other than like
a straight white man like there would be
like a major consequence the
consequences but there would also be
like people are on Twitter always a
cancel Claudia yeah like they always are
saying cancel season 4 whatever but like
there's no outcry when it comes to Alec
Baldwin why is that and I don't want to
start it cuz like I kind of like him I
don't know why like I feel this way I
don't know either but I don't
participate in the cancellations no the
calculation isn't at all um and I'm not
on Twitter but this just seems like one
too many free passes so of course you're
gonna punch someone
when nothing happens when you do and
they wonder if they're moving him to
this suck time slot is just like a
surefire way like no sorry now you stir
fry like a slow way to like back out and
eventually just cancel and maybe this is
like a big story to show wasn't doing
well to begin with cos page six said it
was poorly rated you put Cointreau
something I didn't even hear about it
until he got arrested that was the first
time I heard that he was getting a show
and I'm someone who's so involved I
didn't they must have not put any money
behind advertising it because I didn't
see at the commercial a bus a billboard
uh nothing I didn't know bad I don't
know where I first heard about it but
then I caught a glimpse with Mike Myers
it was so serious and like almost dark
which is like I mean with comedy there
is a dark side so I was glad that they
were getting into that but like you
would think like the Alec Baldwin show I
guess I just assume he's doing Jack
Donaghy too much no I can't separate his
apology for the park the park you think
he denied and he was like I did not
punch someone over a parking spot it's
like I punch someone just it wasn't over
park for a different reason who know
about parking in New York I knew Ben's
mom to tell you what is he doing driving
his own car parking his own car on the
street go to a garage you've literally
made 30 million dollars from 30-watt
spring for the hundred dollar girl sure
no Ben I could tell you Stiles Ben's mom
got a slushy thrown at her by her twin
know by someone someone [ __ ] a bus
stop sign know they'd like those poles a
sign they kicked it it fell on her cart
stat she's gotten into the craziest
because she drives every day so she is
some of the craziest parking spot
stories maybe just crazy stories like a
twin Phaethon final story the headlines
lead to a bit of fake news but it is
indicative of what the larger picture
yes Kaitlyn Bristowe reveals Shawn booth
forgot their anniversary last year so
Kaitlyn caught up with Elle's on her
podcast off the vine Wells is currently
dating Sarah Hyland and they differ on
what their official anniversary date is
and then keel image on we're set
Kailyn was saying that her and Shawn
differ too this was recorded before the
breakup was announced but she did say
she and Truong son tried to figure out
their anniversary as well was it the day
they got engaged we met and had our
first date but I was also dating
multiple men so does that count as our
anniversary or does our anniversary
count as the time we got engaged
needless to say the timeline is rather
muddled for the bachelorette couple he
actually forgot our anniversary last
year Caitlin revealed she continued with
her ex-fiance his reason for forgetting
the day he was like to be fair you had
just dumped a guy five minutes before I
deciding I guess I'll pick this guy okay
at the end of the day you forgot our
anniversary or being a dick right now
just own that also last year he got her
birthday wrong and got her balloons that
said 32 instead of 31 so this was
recorded before the announced so it
wasn't like she's not like oh we broke
up and because her long-term anniversary
but it is weird and also it's like if
you're celebrating our anniversary one
year two years of the day you got
engaged and you're still talking about
the fact that she dumped someone on that
day yeah that's not good she's too young
for you bro you know what it's like as
much as I feel like Kaitlyn and Shawn
are true love like meant to be like I
don't think he was ever really right for
the show like he couldn't handle the the
jealousy and like the the whole concept
of him liking someone who liked other
people and like no one should be
comfortable with that but like he really
like wasn't okay with it that like it
almost I think it ruin that relationship
you know what now like if I could in
hindsight you know what would have been
really interesting and maybe they would
have like had a real shot and this would
have plagued their relationship if there
was no Nick loyal if Britt had won and
was the Bachelorette Shawn would have
left for Kaitlyn because he came for
Kaitlyn and they would probably be
together and they wouldn't think she
wouldn't have dated all those other
people and they wouldn't be in the
spotlight like right I mean it but
nobody cares about Britt they definitely
have a different set of issues yeah but
every couple of them like Britt's
happily married now yeah and no one
bothers her did you have to sell her
pictures of her wedding to People
magazine probably for like three grand
right and now she's like an influencer
go for it is a dream well we're gonna
take a quick break at 11:11 because
we're about to make a wish and it's
about to come true Teresa Giudice will
be joining us momentarily if you have
any questions for the Real Housewives of
New Jersey star please drop a comment on
youtube I will finally start reading
them
she is gonna talk she's an open book
we've been told that she is ready to
talk about whatever so drop a question
let us know what you got to say -
Theresa we'll see you in a little bit
we'll see you in three minutes and in
the meantime while you're waiting go to
shot morning toast calm and get your
merch before you can't notice I only
have 49 more minutes before there's
merch no mo
you
we are back with the queen of New Jersey
miss Teresa Giudice hello Teresa how are
you doing good honey how are you good we
love you you smell so good
ah I think you look so beautiful yeah I
think and we're just obsessed with you
ah we're gonna skin you and wear you
yeah well like where's your lipstick
where's your pants bro where'd you get
your hair dye your hair looks amazing
you have new hair new haircut for new
season yes new haircut new life you also
went like supremely blonde but you've
toned it down a little bit yeah I was
blonder in the summer yeah now yeah dark
I keep going back and forth change with
the season yeah exactly
well we are about to see a new episode
of Real Housewives of New Jersey season
a19
um tonight what are we gonna see what
can we expect from the whole season in
general well I heard it's one of the
best seasons ever
that's a bedroom I'm Andy Cohen is
obsessed he's done episode 10 he's
flipping out like like he's like beyond
it's what we decided which I'm so
excited to because I haven't seen it
right I lived it but I haven't seen it
and I'm happy that he loves it so much
so you know he's getting me all excited
yeah us too we were filming it to you I
feel like oh this is gonna be a great
season one of the greats
you know what I did because one of the
things that you're gonna see this season
is my a new challenge that I went for a
fitness fitness competition so it was
good like focusing on something
challenging myself you know I wanted to
show my daughters you know if you put
your mind to something you could
accomplish it so I'm happy that it was
you know I'm all about being positive
now like I'm just saying well you know
when you're younger you're like you get
things that upset you right away and
like you know you blow up you flip table
so yeah tables Nathan I'm like I just
you know I roll with the punches right
and yeah that's what I'm doing this
season we spoke to Melissa on Friday she
said something that I feel like also
really applies to you she said like she
watches old episodes and she feels like
she's grown up so much like in the few
years that she's been on the show like
when you look back to season one do you
feel like you're a completely different
person oh yeah now then we're back then
like things that would bother me before
what
whatever right I mean you know don't get
me wrong I still about you kind of yeah
hates more it does you know and you have
to push that right button you got me
there
yeah well fine yeah so we have two new
housewives what are your thoughts
they're great I think they're a great
add to the to all of us you know we all
mesh great you know and we do have the
drama mix in it with that you know we
people piss me off and I gotta go but so
but you know I I am happy that they're
both on and finally it's like they stick
yes whoa and I think the fans are gonna
love them yeah we have been through a
roller coaster with some of the new
additions in the past five years
specifically amber I just I just never
understand
you totally yeah Jim James Jimmy Jim Jim
Jim maybe he Bruin did for her yeah they
lent him they were just off so I'm
excited to see two new house sides
we're sofa hopefully I've only heard
good things so far yeah and about Berger
Milani is coming out with this song well
we got so many questions about Milani
everyone wants to know how she's doing
she is the true star of franchise here
and she knows it I think yeah what is it
well yeah it's gonna be debuted on the
show
so then you guys everybody will be able
to download her video oh we will so yeah
so we're waiting for that yeah so I
can't Williams how were you in even Andy
he's so excited he's like oh my god he
has to perform on my trevin's I've I
mean that's something you know we'll
talk about it anywhere
I'll talk to that boiler it spoiler
alert yeah I said you're on watch time
is live tonight yes
is that your favorite part of doing
press for the show I feel like it's so
fun you know what when I first started
doing the show I used to like dread
going I watch what happens live really I
used to think that you know like I'm
like why does he always ask me the
hardest question yeah I don't get it and
I used to like I didn't like it my first
I was aching to me but now I saw him
yeah absolutely adore him we you know we
came really close and you know I want to
make out with them but
you know boys it's unfortunately yeah
but he's really really cute and I just
said don't oh yeah that's a great guy
who are you on with whose other Doris oh
that's fun so are you having an easier
time now getting through to Delores now
that Ziggy is no longer a part of the
show and you still talk to siggy yeah
I've always you know me and divorce we
could just look at each other and we
understand each other yeah that's the
kind of friendship we have I mean it
goes way back over 20 years and like
she's amazing I love her you know I'm
glad to have her in my corner hmm did
you see siggy around town I she doesn't
live in my town okay yeah she doesn't
but you know I love siggy she's great
yeah she really is yeah I've never had
an issue with her and yeah she always
supports me and yeah I'll always support
her do you know if her leaving the show
was a voluntary thing it was her idea or
it was her idea it was yes okay great
well speaking of old and new friends
Danielle this is the season of
Danielle's yes she did no I'm glad she's
you know she's a great she's great for
the show yeah so you guys are still in a
good place
yeah thanks like going off of where you
were at last year's and it continues to
be positive you haven't seen the old
Danielle no I mean the thing is listen
we all have that other side of us yes
when someone pisses us off or anything
like if somebody's in your ear you know
it's like we you know we all have that
side so it's up you know it's either you
click with that person or you don't
mhmmm you know you know not everybody
loves you yeah every night was a grace
you know exactly so we're we're in a
good place
well when Margaret was here the other
day she said that she saw some signs of
not good stuff in Bimini at the wedding
she said that on the wedding night
Danielle and her husband didn't even
sleep in the same bed it cetera oh yeah
I mean you know what I think you know
you guys need to watch this season and
yeah I mean first of all how does she
know them to sleep together right like
was she in bed with them right does she
follow her husband you know back to his
room right to even say that like I don't
know right and I'm gonna I'm close with
Danielle like I didn't know if they sub
together like you know that's second I
guess the question for the you know for
Danielle and Marty to answer so did you
know Marty before did you know anything
about
you met him through Janelle I met him
through Danielle uh-huh yeah and I
thought he was great I mean I'm just
saying like Margaret also if I said
Margaret also let Marty stay with her a
few days like not too long ago so I mean
after this okay I understand so after
they announced it that's not true
it sounds interesting yeah sound good
that's what I heard from Danielle Oh
Danielle I just said Margaret know me
Margaret wants to sleep with him I don't
freaking know I know I'm kidding I'm
kidding
so I can't get Margaret into yell aren't
on great terms okay - mark I have mom
Margaret yeah we love her so as it
stands now who are you you're not a
little bit asleep
no we're here for it yeah so as right
now this is my thing they were really
close
and so you guys got to see how their
friendship unfolds so it's just um it's
hard for me like yeah and I'm torn
between the two of them because they
were really close and I don't know I
don't really get how it went bad she was
a matron of honor and Daniil okay so I
thought you were yeah no yeah I was in
People magazine you could tell yeah I
started beep amazing and if not
market-ready said it so she'd oh you
don't need me for somebody to be a
matron of honor it's a big deal so I
don't get like only them to know exactly
what went down because they were
together all the time really
like all the time oh well maybe they'll
find their way back then if it's just
okay I mean I don't know I'm just saying
like what they double dated like I
didn't do that thing cuz right but with
you they spent a lot of time together
yeah so I don't know and then sluicin
you know when you when your friends or
someone you see things that are not so
cool yeah you know when your friend -
somebody just keep your mouth shut and
you go with it yeah you know yeah you're
a good friend
I understand so I don't know that's a
question but you know that they have you
know you guys have - yeah and like where
it went south yeah so it's Danielle a
full-time cast member the season or
she's a friend of yeah friend I mean
she's upset about that I mean I'm sure
she would love to be a housewife
yeah do you think she'll be coming
wife I don't know that's you know
something man upstairs yes yeah I mean I
think she's great for the show me too
you know we started together yeah I
can't believe how about it I said all
about that like listen if you do me
dirty then I cut you off
yeah so like you know I you know we
started together so I wish you know I
would love for her to continue yeah if
Danielle ever does you wrong like I will
never forgive her because I can't
believe like how many think she knows
that when I was in my bedroom watching
you just give her what she needed
engaged 19 times even though you would
have to start saying now engage 20 times
engage 20 times like I've never forgave
her like and I can't believe that you
like if you had told me back then that
we would be here now and like you guys
would be as close as you are like I
really wouldn't have believed it like
how did you guys even reconnect well
when I was away and I just was thinking
about a lot of things and no obviously
you have a lot of time you think about
everything it just goes through your
mind and and I was doing the yoga and
manifesting and all that so when I came
home I was just like I just wanted to
know no like there's no hard feelings
between us and I wanted her to know that
so I'm I know she's into yoga so I
called her I said you want to go for you
know one of me and do yoga and she was
like yeah like right away like no
hesitation we met then afterward went
for coffee and that's it and she you
know she's like I would like to start
new right and I'm the tape like don't
smother me give me the mic space you
know but Danielle's got a big heart
yeah so she's very gets attached right
away which is a good you know and it's
nice you know because of her past and
everything you know and she's cool like
if you know she gets it like if I need
my space and everything so I mean I've
gotten to know her more because before
she had people in her ear I had people
in my ear right so we really never got
to know each other and that's you know
and then obviously you saw what happened
exposed you know explosion yeah so but
now you know I have got to know her I
think you know she has a great heart
she's I mean she's our friendship have
has grown I'm just saying I see what a
great person she is and yeah you know
she does give it her all and then you
know in a friendship
I feel like Jia was the only one of your
kids who was old enough back then to
maybe even remember Danielle did she
know who she was does she have any
opinion yeah no she's you know when she
came over Jia you know welcome to
England open arms and and even
Danielle's like oh my god I get to talk
to your kids like there Wow
she's like blow it shake they're so
amazing and she just saw because
actually came over I think I join his
birthday and she just saw how my kids
were helping out it's like you know just
pick you know helping me out yeah
everything three girls thank you and she
was just like blown I should and she
spoke to them and she said she was just
really impressed how are your girls
they're good they're good right going on
with their dad we feel we're totally on
your side and I feel like such a grave
injustice has been done to your family
it is our understanding are you
appealing or I mean you can't talk about
it much but you're not sitting down for
this yeah no I mean it's you know I
think we're yeah it's this is the thing
adults could handle anything
it's a children yes it's not fair Yeah
right you're not fair for them yeah it's
like it's a white-collar crime Joe did
what he had to do
he's lip tears whole life he served he's
serving his name's serving his time and
I mean something has to change
it really does yeah well we hope you
figure that out cuz we're like really
sad and I think that everything happens
for a reason at the end of the day there
are worse places that you would have to
go than Italy yeah no I know but still
it's like you know you're like yeah my
first year like this is totally oh you
know and you know it's it's they've been
through enough
yeah they really have yes and they're so
like strong and like normal and
resilient for girls like who could have
gone the other way you know I mean
that's my Milania you know she has had a
hard time with all this so you know
she's been asking me she wants to
singing and rapping and all that she
loves all the music that's out now cardi
B or that's you know you know or the
rapidly practiced she loves them all and
I'm trying to think who else she knows
all the need like all the way other
thought she's truly a character so when
she wanted to do this you know I
supported her it was something to occupy
her mind press herself yes exactly I
understand well I can't wait for the
performance and I will be buying it on
iTunes we still are waiting for another
single from Gia's girl group no no the
terms with the other girls oh she don't
clearly a char that's not what she wants
to do yeah and I love that when she was
into that same that music video was such
high-quality yeah thanks
oh yeah she's like no we went hard for
it yeah I know I love it too but she's
like now she's all about going to school
you know she wants it that's good too
she's going for law Wow
yeah so you know that's also one good
thing comes out of office well I can't
wait to watch everything unfold tonight
eight o'clock
Bravo warehouses in New Jersey at I'm
good
I keep getting the timer comes this is
I'm on Central Time I'm sorry nine
o'clock and you'll be on watch shop
inside afterwards with who wasn't
Dolores Dolores right it'll be a great
episode I'll be tuning in after my shows
in Charlotte tonight you can get tickets
a car with no job back on um Thank You
Teresa for coming ever been beat up with
Teresa and her gorgeous girls Teresa
Giudice on Instagram correct yes and
that's all we got for you we're back
tomorrow Lauren Everts the skinny
confidential will be here for me because
I will be in North Carolina
she'll be feeling unit so if you have
any questions for her feel free to leave
them on Instagram and then I'm back on
Friday before we head to Miami so have
an amazing afternoon when you go to
Miami
I'm corner Miami on Friday you can be
there yeah I'm going to Boca no way sure
thing it's our sister's bachelor party
come oh yeah you have 30 more minutes to
go get your mug shot more Nico's calm
yeah 30 more minutes all the merchants
gonna be gonna never be able to get it
again can you live with that I don't
know thank you guys so much for being
here we'll see you tomorrow
you